howdy I'm Greg
I'm Jeff Goldblum's Jeff Goldblum and I
are gonna watch mommy sacrifice Nestle
Philippines commercial you can guess
there's a new star by the way oh yes oh
yeah okay for the Filipino sub this is a
nia stargazer cuz it's a good setup for
a while I know you know but I'll just
give a brief mention for people who
happen to watch those who aren't part of
our Filipino friends who watch this
channel I've been checking out these
like Filipino commercials that are like
they some some how to get very emotional
Hey yeah I'll be proof of getting
reports yeah this is a nestle
Philippines commercial let me get really
a lousy mom okay and but this is an
animated one I've never seen an animated
comedy or animated stuff yeah so so
beginning that doesn't require subtitles
hopefully
[Music]
there's a waverly place on his knee I
don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you are
oh she doesn't have magic
[Music]
there's no
[Music]
yes like churning hers
magic
[Music]
get some [ __ ] Nestle how no sacrifice
cubed
[Music]
Wow I'm commercial already don't you
think that's in time even it was holy
crap you have not seen a Filipino
commercial you see this appearing right
here your touch is enough mom yeah
that's a tearjerker right yeah kind of
gets me you see I have to got cried in
like four there's been a couple where
I'm like I got a little bit the odd I
didn't cry but there's been like there
was when I saw Kyle Kyle I started
crying because this is like animated
overlay not it is like family-friendly
kitty like you know like and and there's
a whole like crazy magical plot
happening
yeah so you don't identify it yeah with
the kids even when all that Matt really
really yeah I mean it's like I couldn't
even tell when world was took place in I
can't even tell what was going on look
imagine what are the rules of this yeah
are you going away yeah kid it's coming
through so then when she put it away
everything went back to mute well it
looks like they gave her magic powers
yeah so she so she could have magic yeah
but the in turn they would not have me
yes that's what I get it she gave up the
choice yeah we went caught on yeah yeah
clarify guys like while I was watching
him like what happened yeah it looked
like they were like everything I am like
oh right yeah yeah and then I was like
oh I see I see what time yeah the moms
do worth their asses off they do moms
are awesome this is really cute it was
adorable it wasn't like it was as well
animated I guess this is what the
Philippines is really like having been
there since I was 3 years old
yeah it's changed a lot it doesn't even
go on a magic wand out on Aaron second
America wait rhumba you know what the
Phillip
looks like way better than human he
could go to Hogwarts yeah this is crazy
it's like witches away but I thought
there was like the wizard away with a
place commercial yeah you're watching
Disney you know the Japanese I don't
want to I don't we go with the milk
though I like to know no it's cool
there's some suggestive things on here
oh my goodness with the dad and the girl
with the rocket looking like a penis
going into town I was gonna say giantess
I was gonna say it looked like a rocket
launching hey that's what I was going to
say going into outer space
yeah you seek out the unknown it's like
Star Trek that is the beauty of Gregory
Elbe yeah when you get a neato on the
channel whoever is sick it doesn't have
the same Hyneman and Joe Brennan comes
up rings that would be sexual
frustration within him what can I say
any are you bringing out of me adult I'm
sexy and something help y'all yes I mean
no you forney sexy munchkin understand
utterly Teddy pick like that I'll eat
anything about a dirty talker a book
yeah it's really cute oh yeah I just
want to know what are you getting cuddle
- a daddy you can't wait to hold your
body close love it can we default sleep
on the couch I can cover you with a
blanket laughs a pillow under your head
this is all promotion for Nestle is
great well it's off toppings it's all
for nothing sleep yeah you gotta have
you gotta have some Nestle chocolate in
your life you sure I'm gonna chocolate
in your life which is another reason why
I love Greg do what yeah hi Renee I know
don't remind me he produces milk too you
see the thing with the other commercials
though is even though the other
commercials are emotional they have
these stories I always think like I'm
gonna remember what this product was
really obviously not yeah I remember the
commercial farad I remember the
commercial and it does every time the
commercial ends I'm like kind of lunch
either even though it's never about
product it makes me kind of like there's
a coca-cola I really make you want to
try it you got a watch one of it
there's Nestle one I was like where does
the Nestle say yeah yeah I really got
her good I would pull into the people
and it was it was like we were wondering
where is Nestle
see my fare are you Nestle my family was
opposite my dad was home and my mom
would come out of work but she wasn't
like this way with our lawns you know my
behind my dad wasn't really you know
like he's doing gloom did your dad
wasn't like let's go play with our
garden don't don't
he hated magic I would kind of like if
they redid this commercial but they did
it with like my show like a real life
like humans since that would be cool I
think it would be a lot cooler to have
made it with real humans but maybe they
didn't know the budget for it are you
talking to me Nestle could be going out
of it you don't know their life you
don't know them an animated version I
feel like that's the kind of dad I might
be one day but I don't really want to
stay at home wife
I want a nanny oh my woman working well
I'm working on my goals she's providing
the bill that's grace why wouldn't she
you know the wind I imagine the rest of
my life is me trying to figure my [ __ ]
out all my woman takes care of the child
from financial support and the nanny
does the rest
nanny does the real raging hair I'll try
helping them with their homework yeah
you know yeah teaching them the way to
the website you got to become rich you
just have to become rich but you know
what you can't do that on YouTube you've
gotta do it on patreon we're back so you
will have a good rich patreon
contributors Terry $30 it's so very
little you can help somebody become rich
that could say like 10 African
children's lives um African American
[Laughter]
gosh he's just people thicker everyone
well is that why the $3.00 name is
african-american child honestly it would
because they make it heat
I'm talking about Africa how many
McDonald's sandwiches you can get for $3
- you can get serious families exactly
that's how many people you know when you
see those ads and say for a week for
like a dollar you could take care of an
average and child with me online I don't
know if I believe that
yeah I ever something I'm like oh is it
like a couple bucks well maybe one of
our American dollars is like equal to
like 5 million caprica in African
America you will provide this child life
insurance if you donate five no the
dollar will go straight to the trust
fund yeah and it will just be the dollar
and they will be set for the rest so you
can either contribute to a child's life
in Africa who doesn't have a YouTube
channel or even make the sandwich or you
can become a part of our patreon apart
patreon received a $3 reward reward and
behind-the-scenes that's not what three
dollars three dollars I know I would you
know I would do it ten dollars which can
save an orphanage of African children's
to African American adoration I'm not
being racist it's the rib in the
afternoons in Africa you know the
animation for a commercial animated
commercial this is really pretty damn
good Adam like if this was a TV show be
like I don't know how long I can watch
it - but a commercial that's really damn
good animation Filipinos and their
artistic Missy on it's the Manny
Pacquiao yes assemble some memory
doesn't hurt my shoulder the other day
that's
that's how he lost his fight to
Mayweather okay because you're his
shoulders right yeah how did you hurt
your children I got out of bed the wrong
with you generally for just to the wrong
way the wrong way I tried getting on the
floor my hands are your ring well you
don't have an X I put in my head like -
menial try exercises on my video
Rhiannon grandma pretty far right yes
great YouTube channels totally subscribe
today oh yeah yeah you got patriotic
time to explain it
watch yo their video find out hey I need
a star gazer channel from a needed star
house thing you need a star gazer
channel become a sardis your keys at the
stars
yeah the thunders are I'm think of Anita
that's what I do I'll get the star you
should I think you everyone to associate
me with star gazing
every time I look at the Stars I go
Moneta she's right there because I
believe we are all on me present so this
is like in the current time in which my
mind can comprehend you are a live to me
alone but when I look at the Stars
because omnipresent is all time is that
me yeah it really has a future present
it's all one time anyway God works and
looking at the star and alien that's you
deaf yeah right God your omlet know what
I think we're on two very different ages
look how I see stars does you dead stars
can you be on the stars exactly No
yeah you look up you look down a people
cousins like I'm down here and there and
then you go remember who you are do you
do remember oh no I need to shake you
remand
I'm not Ryan Wright you only see the
chair you gotta go back and reread read
it again
Ryan Wright would get terrible the
apocalypse man he would Michelle with me
Shania we're gonna put a vet April
Fool's video the one we did a different
one we did was interesting no hot and
sexy and then I died that was by Ronan
seen it by now
oh we got sixty three thousand views oh
my god I'm so sorry that it only god
that's like the whole channel that I
have collectively ecliptic I'll be
saying probably not even more people
probably will watch this mom now
now with all nobody home you do know you
know what it says nobody not even appear
this is retired for too long what
centigrade